[Music]
i just want to say welcome to everyone
um and i'm gonna go ahead and just get
started with some brief
introductions so as i said my name is
saba khan
and i'm a member of the mba admissions
staff and we are extremely fortunate
today
to be joined by professor huggie rau who
teaches organizational behavior here at
stanford
he's also the author of scaling
excellence a wall street journal
bestseller and we're also extremely
fortunate to have
kay foster joining us and
hopefully you've all had a chance to
take a look at our so-called homework
that we sent you ahead of time
um and you've had a chance to take a
look at this wonderful case
about kaye's experience being
exceptional
not an exception and
from here i'm gonna let huggy take it
away and throughout the course of our
discussion you can feel free to
submit questions via the q a box
fabulous thank you so very much saba
for that very gracious introduction uh
good evening everybody
greetings from stanford i'm hagie rao
i'm a professor at the graduate school
of business at stanford university
and we're all very grateful that you've
taken the time to be with us today
it's a privilege to be of help to you so
thank you
today we have an extraordinary guest and
that
is my wise smart
witty i could go on and on just on w's
alone
k foster how do i describe k
for k k is a person who
[Music]
who really i think has done just the
most marvelous job i know
of actually activating and creating a
franchise around her best self
those of you who are joining us today on
monday we actually had another session
and in that session one of the things i
was suggesting to all of you was
as you think of business schools you may
be
prone to or you may be seduced by the
active product
comparison where you compare business
schools as products and create a giant
matrix and it sounds like a wonderful
thing to do
however i've often wondered as to
whether that was a decoy problem
a problem designed to distract you from
the real
problem because the real challenge is
not choosing amongst products when we
choose schools when we choose
jobs we don't choose products we
actually
choose amongst different versions of our
life
we choose one version of our life as
opposed to another
and one of the things i had suggested on
monday was
that in a pandemic it's actually hard
for us to choose one version of life
because we're in a room called fear
if you're afraid how can you actually
choose oneself amongst many selves
it's very difficult because we have
tunnel vision we have
we are risk-averse and so on and
we need to be in a room called hope
because when we have hope as some wise
philosopher put it hope
is a rope so we can actually clutch that
rope and it can take us places and it
can lead to aspiration
and what's the passageway from the room
called fear
to the room called hope what i have
suggested was
that all of you get in touch with your
best self
what is your best self it's the self
that kind of
you know usually you can get in touch
with your best self
by simply asking yourself hey
if there were three adjectives three
verbs three adverbs
used that i can use to describe myself
what are they
that'll actually help you get in touch
with your best self
you can look back in your life you may
be at home you may be at work there was
a time at war
there was a time when you felt you were
at your zenith your peak
you felt exhilarated accomplished
stretched maybe that's your best self
or maybe if you're in a project team
and if k is the project team leader she
asks you
hey choose a job title that showcases
your best self
that's another way in which you can
access your best self
what do best selves do they actually
help us
focus on what we want to do and
getting in touch with the best self is
actually an
art and that's the reason we actually
offer you the case study
with k's generous wisdom and cooperation
about the trajectory of our own life
now to a description of k because your
job is to ask questions i will curate
them
and k is going to answer them see i
leave the difficult
task for her and the reason is k is
a person who's extraordinarily
accomplished
but the defining feature of k is how
likely she carries those accomplishments
on her shoulders as she is fond of
saying
her career can be seen as an arc from
the toilet
to the tower and if you read the case
study
you will see how she began when she was
a young
teenager 19 or so from barbados coming
to new york
being a cleaning lady and then going to
baruch and then
attending nightcon and then attending
columbia business school
you all know of the episode of her free
first day at columbia business school
where she was asked
by somebody do you go to school and her
instant realization that
while she may demographically be an
exception
she really had to come to terms with the
fact that she was
exceptional and then others would of
course understand that very easily
just think of that act of insa that act
of recognition
the flash of insight remarkable and if
you look at her career
from her beginnings in colombia she
reached the executive suite of j
j after j jnj she was part of a team
that
actually was involved in the successful
ipo of onyx a big
biopharmaceutical company and today
she's on the board of
more biotech companies than i can come
she's uh you know the chairman the
chairperson of the
glide foundation in san francisco on the
board of the stanford hospital
an advisor to carlisle an advisor to bcg
and i can assure you i've only scraped
the tip of the iceberg
she's a trustee at spelman she's a
person
who truly truly gives voice to the
voiceless
and in all of my interactions what i've
seen kate do is
she makes others and indeed the idea is
given by others
bigger and better and she does that with
rare humility
extraordinary wisdom and amongst all the
people in the c-suite i've seen
there's only one person i know who says
i'm going to master one word for the
next two months a word called complexity
and she's talking to you know
biophysicists and physicists and
management characters
like myself and god knows what
remarkable person
join me in extending a warm welcome to k
foster please
okay i'm going to do an indian namaste
and say thank you
thank you my friend it's wonderful to be
here can you guys hear me
yes absolutely good good good well thank
you uh huggy i
really uh first of all appreciate the
space that you have created
for me to share my story to answer
questions um
and uh the thing the reason i like doing
these kinds of uh you know experiences
is because i am a lifelong learner
and there is never a time that i don't
walk away from an experience that i
don't learn
so interestingly enough when you did the
introduction and um
asked the attendees to think about
three words that describe themselves of
course i could not help but do the same
thing
so my three words are compassionate
curious and charitable beautiful
that's beautiful each one reinforces
another and they truly define who you
are you know when i sort of see that
absolutely curious compassionate and
charitable and there you have it
cave foster with us this evening what
i'd love for the audience to do is
use the q a option uh to
to um can we
pull up the q a option please so use the
q a option
to ask questions of k i'd like to curate
them so that as you ask
questions i might bundle a couple of
them
and get them going
if you're having trouble with the q a
box there is one question that's come in
already can you
really wait one second okay
yeah go ahead why don't you take that
please great
um so we have a question um
coming in from jimmy who's asking
and i'm just going to read it in the way
that oh yeah
i can pull that up can i just keep
behind you saba
please okay what a beautiful question
charlie
charlie says thank you for sharing the
intimate story about
your interaction with the lady with the
chanel bag
looking back on your experience what
would you say to the
the other woman to yourself just
starting at colombia
great question charlie so what would i
say to myself
at that time or to the chanel bag lady
but okay so with obviously with the
with the benefit of hindsight right
because as i as i mentioned at that
point in time
it was uh it really shook me to my core
and now looking back with the with the
benefit of hindsight
i would have done with her what i do now
because no surprise to you there are
many places where i am still
the only female the only
person of color and sometimes the only
female of color
and when i am at times met with
a question about whether or not i am in
quite a
quote-unquote the right place i
generally
in those circumstances engage
truly from a place of curiosity because
i am
intellectually curious about
why an individual that has encountered
me
has a particular mindset
perspective you may call it bias that's
causing him
or her to react or respond to me
in a questioning way and the principle
that allows me to engage with them not
from a place of
anger or even disappointment
is unconditional positive regard and
it's how i try to walk through life
which is to hold out
an intention to engage with that person
unconditionally and holding them with
positive regard
even in the face sometimes of over
racism or over sexism
and therefore i i when i engage for
example to be very specific
i i would say to the person and i've
done this before um
what is it about this encounter with me
that causes that question to
to come up for you am i in the right
place
is it because you have an assumption
about where my place
is or where my place should be and
i am here because i've earned the right
to be here
so if you are open to engaging with me
i'm open to having a conversation with
you about
what is it about this encounter in this
place
the juxtaposition of those two things
that's causing a query in you
and again i do it from a place of
unconditional positive regard
because i have found that holding that
place
in life as i engage with people
it enables me to engage them in a
fundamentally different way
and to myself i would have urged
patience uh because
at the moment that that happened as
as i said i was shocked i didn't know
what to do about it i
i responded from a place of naivete
because i didn't understand what was
happening
and the little voice in my head if i
were looking back and giving that
young woman young woman advice i would
say
as my mother says patience my dear
patients
you're a mute huggy thank you
uh
thank you so very much uh you know
for that wonderfully detailed textured
and nuanced response
daniela has a question often
times being the only person in the room
that looks like us
or being classified as non-traditional
what would you tell your younger
self to move through the process of
believing that you're not
an exception but exceptional
yeah you know huggy it starts with how
you started this right
so much of this starts with your own
sense of yourself
and you know an understanding of
what it is that you bring of value
and so often we don't do the work to
understand that or
what i find when you're younger and
you're you're growing
you're thinking about the achievement or
the accumulation
of things that you believe will create
status for you because you are still in
pursuit of status particularly
if i think about my younger self when i
you know
throughout most of my career i was the
as i said the only person of color the
only woman
and i've told you on you and bob
sutton's stories of being in vietnam
uh at a point in time where uh
i i was just i was a curiosity for
people
and this was back in the early 90s uh
when i was in in
vietnam so i've grown
not just comfortable but i've i've grown
confident in my difference and so often
we encourage people to get comfortable
in their difference
i'm urging people to get confident in
their difference
and the difference for me is real value
i was just just before this call
i was coaching a ceo
of an extraordinary company and he said
to me
he's only 32 years of age he's young
it's a company in the biotech
space he's not a scientist and his
entire leadership team and most of his
company
are composed it's composed of people who
are deep experts in the sciences
deep experts in technology and he said
you know
it's one of the things that he's
struggling with because he's
in his head and that was the advice i
gave him i said you know
the single most important thing that you
have to become
is confident in your difference
and the way that you need to manifest
that is
asking the right questions you as the
ceo
you don't have to have the right answers
you have to have the right questions
because if you have the right team
around you
that team will have the answers right
you have to ask the right questions to
spark
the insight and to spark for them
the the inquiry that gets the
quote-unquote the right answer
so i would say that's how i would answer
that question brilliant
there are lots of questions coming up
richly generative case study i'm going
to bundle a bunch of these things
mikhail shin says what gave you the
power
to overcome disbelief stereotyping and
social deprivation the way maybe i'd
like to modify it
and anna laura right after him actually
asks
sometimes people think i'm just a
diversity number
what advice do you have for us that feel
the impostor syndrome
to actually overcome it and here okay
you mentioned two words don't be
comfortable be
confident so can you share with the
others
the call as to how self-discovery
leads to self-affirmation or is it the
other way around
no i do believe self-discovery and i
don't think it's linear
right i think that we as human beings
are dynamic
individuals and i think so often and you
you hug
you hear me say all the time aspire for
linear but plan for discontinuous and
disruptive
that is uh for me that's a model for
life that's not just about
projects or work that's a model for life
and
therefore getting confident
getting comfortable um
is a is a process and and my mother
would always
talk about perfection is the enemy of
progress
and she said so often we focus on
perfection
and we lose track of the progress over
time so
for me what that looks like is i i am
genuinely
first of all i approach life as a
blessing
every you know i say this all the time
every morning that i wake
and i'm six feet above ground as opposed
to six feet below ground is a good day
so everything else is upside from there
so it starts i think with this
affirmation
of yourself and your presence that you
deserve
to be a presence on the planet right
and the imposter syndrome is
alive and well i go through that at
times as you could imagine there are
times when
i am i mean i can pick a board meeting
when i
am at a board meeting and i am with as a
matter of fact
a board that i recently joined the
companies in stealth mode
on the board is one of the former
commissioners of the fda
a nobel laureate um
you know people who were former ceos
of incredibly successful companies right
and i remember when i quote resumed but
walked into the first meeting it was
kind of like
the reality of all of these people
um hit me and i've got to go back and
say to myself
i was chosen because i belong here
because there's something of value that
i have to bring
and it's what i'm going to urge our
audience to be
really clear about what is the value
that you bring
and don't numerate your value by your
degrees
by your achievements numerate your value
by
who you are right and that's where the
self-affirmation comes from
and the exercises that you give them are
brilliant
what's three words that really speak to
the essence of you
right and how do you take those words
and then have actions that actually
reflect
those words what i call the intention
experience gap how do you make sure
that the intention for your life is
reflected in the
experiences that you live and the
experience that others have
of you beautiful right that's a that's
beautifully put
okay here's a very mischievous and very
pointed question from alexandra
alexandra asks you is your approach
different when you encounter racism and
sexism
from another woman of color ah
thank you alex round that's a brilliant
question so i'm going to tell you my
my journey because as i said i came
from the caribbean i'm of barbadian
descent
was raised in the british system because
we were colonized by the british
so i was i was raised with oxford and
cambridge
certificate so in the british system
came to the u.s
and often particularly uh
in colombia and as i started my early
career people would
say to me especially when i am
you know typically the only woman or the
only person of color
people would look and they would say to
me hmm
um
what is your name and i would speak my
name and they would say
and then they would hear me and they
would say oh
where are you from and you know i'm very
proud i'm from barbados
and then the response would be oh
that explains it and in my early naivete
i had no idea what that meant
but it's by doing my own work and doing
a lot of work to understand the
roots of structural and systemic racism
and how it manifest
in this country i came to understand
that by continuing to separate myself
out and when people would say oh you are
different
i would actually be so thrilled that i
was
recognized as different what i
understood
that i actually was doing a disservice
to the collective black experience that
i
should have been a part of and i was a
part of
so it's only when i came to realize that
what was happening in that instant
was an individual was
had a particular let's call it a
phenotype of stereotype of a black
person
i did not fit that phenotype of
stereotype
and because they were so wedded to that
bias or that stereotype
they had to make me an exception and put
me in a box
and for a long time until i understood
what was happening
i would set myself apart and therefore i
actually started to internalize a lot of
the
negative stereotypes that existed in
this country about black people and i
needed to go on
my own journey to claim my identity as a
black person
in this country with all of the
dimensions of what that meant
and therefore what you're probably
talking about is
colorism because i also
encountered colorism as well or the
infamous and some of the
folks on the phone will understand this
on the zoom
i was joining a jack and jill
and was subject to the brown paper bag
test
and i will i will leave it at that and
i guess i was close enough to the color
of the brown paper bag because i was
admitted
again naively not even understanding
the underlying structural and systemic
racism within our own community
and that's why this journey of life is
so important and who you are
and how your experience connects or is
reflected in your intention
ultimately my intention was to show up
fully claiming
my identity as a black person in this
country with all of the challenges
and the benefits and uh
that that's that was a journey there's
no question about it that was a journey
so there are a number of questions your
mom's a big hit
okay so one lovely question about your
mom is
your mom said the people you step
on on the way up or the people you meet
on the way back
down yes so the question that's being
asked is
what do you do to support people small
little actions that you do to actually
uh go out of your way to support other
people yeah
so a couple of things um at this
particular point in my life
i i do believe that i am so enormously
blessed
that i used to say
in in one of my iterations i would say
when i leave the earth i want to be
all used up i want to take everything
that i have
everything that i've given and i want to
just
use every single thing in service of
others
i have gotten much more um specific now
at this point in time i am really
focused on
women of color women and men of color
particularly black men
black men and women and what that looks
like is everything from
uh taking a call because there are times
when people
are referred to me they send me a note
through linkedin and say i saw you doing
something
i know you're really busy i'm a
first-year student
or you know i just moved to this country
so those are simple things i mean the
most precious resource
i have all of us have is our time
so if i take time to have a 30 or 40
minute conversation with some person
that's an investment in them and
huggy you and bob have been gracious
enough to send a number of students
that i've had the absolute pleasure of
mentoring
from some of them from from africa some
of them from
from the u.s so that's one i vote with
my
time the second is i sit on the board of
spelman college
and by sitting on the board of spelman
college i actually
get throughout the course of my time on
the on the board
to really create greater opportunities
and not just opportunities
but insight you know i think it was uh
maya angelou who said
or maybe it was i can't remember if it
was her or marion wright edelman maybe
it was my own right edelman
who said you have to see it to be it
so at this stage in my life for
men and women of color particularly
i want to see it i want them to see me
so that they can have a vision of what
is possible for them
that's the second and then the third i
actually
use my network to create connection
and that's part of the asset that i have
now
is i'm blessed to have an extraordinary
network
and that's what i do i use that network
in service of others everything from
helping people
find connections around funding
advice business plans even things as
i was uh at an appointment and there was
a young woman who had just come back
from maternity leave
and uh in the midst of covet and trying
to deal with everything
um and i asked her i knew she just had a
baby second baby i said
how's the baby how are you doing she
burst into tears and it didn't take so
so i'm at the doctor's appointment i'm
at the doctor's office for an
appointment
and i end up taking care of the doctor
which i think is pretty funny
but it's my only point is
there are always opportunities for
kindness and then simple things like
you know i keep dollars
i know you will think this is very weird
but i learned this from my mother
so in my pockets uh i keep like single
dollars or coins because it's inevitable
you're going to meet some person
who is going to be in need and instead
of not seeing them
or walking past them easy enough to put
your hand in your pocket and give some
person
something that they can go buy a cup of
coffee or something with
that's i don't know how else but to be
who i am
and that is who i am yeah there are a
number of people
who of course are saying in the q and a
column how much how inspired they are by
you
um giselle for example says
she often feels like the only woman of
color in the room as does nikki for
instance
and then sawa imosili
asks you what about you have you sought
mentors in your life
how have the mentors and your and
sponsors in your life
supported you and then rashmi has a
follow-up question to that and where
rashmi says
what is the difference according to you
between mentorship
sponsorship and advocacy when is my
favorite question that is my
absolute favorite question so um
uh and i do make the distinction across
all three so to answer the first
question
i have had and continue to have mentors
uh throughout my life and i have
i call the best way to describe them is
a portfolio of mentors right
there are people in my life who um
[Music]
hear deeply about me my career
my progress who i am so
early in career interestingly enough
most of my mentor sponsors and advocates
were white males
and that was just a function of the time
in which my career was unfolding
that the leadership ranks that was what
was in the leadership ranks
um later in my career i have had
more women who have mentored me who have
sponsored who've been advocates for me
but even to this day i continue to uh
to have mentor sponsors and advocates
and
it's a reciprocal relationship and i do
believe in the bounty of the universe
so you some people call it karma some
people call it kismet
for me it's the bounty of the universe
to answer the second question
for me mentorship is um
that's more informal that is some person
who
you can ask questions that is some
person who
it does not have to be a relationship of
hierarchy
it can be a peer mentor uh the person
doesn't even have to be in your
organization or even in the same
sector of work that you're in but it's
some person that you
can ask just about any question you can
ask that person
um you know i'm having i'm struggling
with this particular issue
um can i just call you and chat about it
so for me mentoring is more informal
it is it doesn't that person as a mentor
doesn't necessarily
have this political capital
to be able to use on your behalf right
because your mentor could be a
subordinate and that's the other thing i
say to people
we sometimes get very hierarchical about
these things
and i find that i am constantly learning
from people
who are earlier in career than i am so
that's mentor
sponsor is some person who is willing
to look out for you who is willing to
think about you even when you're not in
the room
and it could be everything from a work
assignment
it could be and it's not just that the
person
is asking you for advice or you're
asking for advice
there's a bit more formality to it
that's some person who's helping you
think about your career
helping you think about your life and
they're willing
to actively engage and sponsor you
advocacy
is some person who is willing to use
his or her political capital on your
behalf
with no expectation of a return
so for me advocacy there's a
selflessness about advocacy and i'm
willing to take the risk because it at
times it's risky and i've been in this
situation where people have done this
for me
so i used to work at pfizer and i had
was a couple years out of graduate
school
and i worked in the manufacturing plant
that was my first job i worked in the
manufacturing plant in a lean
production system trans uh
transformation in the in a
very old line manufacturing plant and
then i
was moved to the corporate headquarters
and
there was the head of hr at the time
i got to know him and he said to me
well what would you like to do how do
you want your career to unfold
and i said to him i really do think it's
important that i get
global experience but i'm not sure
given that i was just starting planning
to start a family
i'm not sure that i can take a post
overseas
about a week later he had created an
opportunity for me to join a team
and be the head of hr for a region
called jala japan
asia africa middle east and latin
america and it did not require me
as long as i was willing to do this it
did not require me
to move to the region because think
about it where would i have moved japan
where in asia latin america it wasn't
practical and that was what was so
genius about what he did
but remember now this is my only my
second assignment
this is a a part of the business that
the aspiration is eight billion dollars
in revenue
and i am this relatively early in career
uh hr leader and he advocated for me
and not just advocated for me he then
made sure
that i had the right kind of support
structure or support system to make me
successful so that's the distinction
i make between those three that's very
helpful
missy mischievously notes that these are
great takeaways on world kindness day by
the way
i did not know that
thank you missy for that little shout
out
so northwater asks an interesting
question
on whose shoulders does the burden land
for being exceptional is it you who
internalize it
or should those whom you encounter
should they realize you're
exceptional
so so you know as i i am a product of my
environment we're all products of our
environment and in the case you heard
uh me talk about the fact that um my
early
years were in a british colony
with extraordinarily high standards
from a family system that had very high
standards
and even when i came to this country and
i was cleaning bathrooms
i knew that the expectation
for my life from my parents and my
family
was going to be uh around that
exceptionality
it was not going to be and that cleaning
the bathroom
was part of the journey it was not the
stop
right so i do think that the
and i don't think of it as a burden uh
one of the things that
hopefully people have started to
understand about me is
i have an intentionality about language
because
language does create reality and it
creates constructs from which we operate
so if i if i think about exceptionality
or that or being an exception or being
exceptional as a burden or a challenge
it's like something i've got a fight
it's like something i've got to be ready
and i've got to be armed as opposed to
it's an opportunity so all of a sudden i
am now
opening up and i'm thinking wow it's an
opportunity so i'm thinking innovation
i'm thinking wow you know that that's
really interesting what is being
exceptional mean what are all the
different ways in which i could show up
as being exceptional as opposed to
oh my gosh this is a burden so language
does matter
i i think of being exceptional
and again i want to really encourage
the participants to be unapologetically
confident not arrogant right
be unapologetically confident
about who you are and what you have to
bring to the table and it takes time
it is a journey so i'm not you don't
magically become that
but i'm really gonna urge you to think
about yourself from that place
and really have a vision for yourself
and for your life
that really is about being exceptional
right and
exceptional will show up in many
different ways it's not just quote
unquote acing the test
right that that's one measure you could
use that as a measure of exceptionality
for me being exceptional is about the
life that i'm leading
right at the end of at the end of my
days
will i be able to say that i
use the gift of life in the most
meaningful way that i could that's
to me is what exceptional is about right
and hopefully that's what people see
and you know that the council i would
give them um i'm going to read something
because i sent it to my daughter
yesterday because um she's 19 years old
and like you know 19 year olds
she is on her journey and i sent this to
her yesterday
because uh she at times like so many of
us
me included it's a quote from michelle
maros
and it says it is totally and completely
okay
for people not to like you or understand
you
what matters is how you love
honor and accept yourself
your life is a masterpiece it doesn't
have to make sense
to anyone else and that's when you get
yourself rooted
in in in things like that that's that's
what starts to define
uh being exceptional
so number of questions okay this is
wonderful
and very inspiring so one sort of ques
one set of questions is
has to do with you're so accomplished
you overcame so many obstacles did you
ever want to throw in the towel in at
some point and say
you know what this is not for me i'm
going to give up
and then there's another lovely question
from cher
who says you had of course the benefit
of
extraordinary parents and you know a
mother and father
and all of that he says what happens how
do you what's your advice to people who
have
a broken childhood how do you overcome
that trauma yeah so i'll answer the
first one
uh of course i am human so there are
days
when i literally would like nothing more
than to pull the covers over my head and
you know go live on an island somewhere
and uh
you know just sit on sit by the beach
and put my
feet in the water and then reality
happens so
um i i back to knowing about myself
i am wired in a particular way
but i will tell you that one of the
most challenging moments that i had was
more around the physical limitations
of my body so huggy and bob know that
i've had
a couple of really challenging
circumstances
a couple years ago i climbed kilimanjaro
and i it was just
extraordinary and just before i
started the summit i was having knee
pain
and i convinced the surgeon to give me a
shot of cortisone
in the knee so that i could make it up
the mountain and make it back down
and when i came back down i went right
in and had the surgery and that
started a series of
um i can describe
a series of traumas i had both of my
knees operated on
i then ended up breaking of
breaking my foot and shortly after that
i ended up with spine surgery
and those were i would say the most
challenging parts of my life because
so much of my ability to function
i had you know i was a power lifter so
some of the physicality
uh was a way of expressing power for me
and i've had to learn to overcome that
there were
absolutely days and and my back went out
i was
in uh in the in the in ecuador
in the jungle embedded with indigenous
tribes
and uh being airlifted out is uh
was uh was uh was challenging so it's in
those moments when it just
felt like it would have been easier to
just given up
but it was definitely more physical and
what was interesting
is what helped me to overcome those
moments
was believe it or not surrender
and what i mean by that is i literally
had to surrender to what was happening
to my body this was the one time i could
not power
through i couldn't walk right
for quite some time i couldn't walk for
quite some time
i you know i had a hole in my back and
uh
in that moment what was interesting was
surrendering
was the most powerful thing giving up
was the most powerful thing
that i could do as opposed to trying to
push through so
that's i mean i hope that answered your
question but that is just
me at my most vulnerable um
really really challenging your your
second question
about when you don't
have the blessing of parents who are
either
intact or with you um
you know i i say that mother
is a verb not a noun
and therefore when you think about even
parent to parent not parent
because i think that's what is what i
have learned
is if you think about those things as
a noun if you think about mother as a
noun father as a noun
parent is a noun it is embodied in the
presence of an
individual but if you think about
mother father parent as a verb you have
the opportunity then
to have people who are not necessarily
your kin
people who are not quote unquote your
traditional
parent mother father to have the
experience of having them
mother you father you parent you
and interestingly enough in my life
that's what i do because i know how
blessed i am
and that's one of the things i do i
really really subscribe to this notion
that mother is a verb it's not a noun
and therefore anyone can be
mothered father men can mother others
right i love that uh
i love that insight kay that mother is a
verb and not a noun
i'm going to share that with my mother
when i talk to her
and i'm going to blame you for this
says to me there are a number of others
who are enchanted by the books that you
read
and in particular they're all touched by
the advice you gave your daughter
so the question they're asking is are
there other books that
you read and you would recommend to them
wow um so i am a
voracious reader because i'm so curious
and i read
everything and i mean everything so tell
i will tell the participants if you want
to send me um
book recommendations i am always looking
to read and i'm generally reading
both hard copy books as well as
audio books because i used to be a
runner i can only walk now because of my
multiple surgeries
but i listen to books and i read the
full spectrum
one of my favorite books is by victor
franco
man's search for meaning um i
i love uh books that are i call them
messy family dramas
so the vanishing half that came out this
year i
love that book um there is a book called
educated by uh tarnower i cannot
remember what her first name is but it
is a true story of a woman and i see a
lot of my story in her
of a young woman who grew up
in a very rural part of the country
and her family lived off the grid
they had a certain set of beliefs that
caused them to really in many ways
reject
traditional systems like education and
all those things so
most of her brothers and sisters were
not educated and
she did not go to school but had this
urge within herself and desire within
herself that propelled her
from that all the way to harvard
university
uh just an extraordinary story so i
i don't hesitate at all i mean i read
everything from white fragility
cast you know you name it i read it um
i'll put it in there put it in the chat
but uh please tell the participants that
and oh by the way um i also read the
bible
so this year i decided that what i was
going to do
was i was going to read the bible from
the very beginning to the end
and i mean i've grown up in the church
like so many people
but the stories in the bible are
fascinating
and i am looking at them through the
lens of leadership
huggy you will appreciate this hopefully
so will the audience
and where i have been spending a fair
bit of time on drawing analogies to
where we are
now in our own political uh
challenge and maybe maybe this is you
know people might not find it relevant
but
i think of the journey of the israelites
to the promised land uh escaping
slavery under the egyptians and the fact
that
even with this bold promise so many of
them stayed behind
and as they were moving through uh the
40 years
through the wilderness they were
disobedient ungrateful begged for manna
when they got mannered then they wanted
meat
then it was about water and this this
really
interes it is such an interesting story
and has so many lessons about leadership
because then the kings
came can emerge from those stories and
even as they went to the promised land
so many of them
wanted to return to slavery under the
egyptians
because it represented security and what
they knew
so for me it's fat it's a fascinating to
look at it that way
as opposed to these are just bible
stories
these are leadership like real
leadership lessons like the kings
all the kings and kind of you know it
speaks to
the the in some ways the fragility of
leadership as well so anyway i could go
on because i
love love love reading how much you read
there are so many great questions and i
feel guilty because
i would love to ask you all these
questions and we just don't have the
time but i'm going to close with
one last question by maru mari choi
and he really teased up a very important
issue and she says
as an ambitious woman how do i manage
work and family yeah
so first of all i'm gonna say i am so
proud of you for claiming ambition
because so many women
um really are hesitant to claim that
they
are ambitious and what i say to people
there is no value
it's not good or bad ambition is an
aspiration
right it's an expression blind ambition
is different but i am just so proud of
you for claiming the fact that
you are an ambitious woman
uh one of the things that i learned is
we often try to ba we talk about balance
and when you talk about balance
it implies that you somehow reach this
stasis
this magical place and over my
61 years over my you know 40 plus
years of work it is clear that there are
going to be times
when work is going to take precedence
and you've got to then figure out how do
you
negotiate and i talk about contract
early and often
right because the dynamism of the
relationship
it changes over time and as some person
i i say to people the casualty
of my extraordinary success and
inattention
is a divorce but i will tell you
that that is because i was striving for
this balance
working really hard at work feeling
completely guilty all of the time and
over time
i just said work is the path
and that's a that's a lesson it's not a
regret i have two amazing children
so i have no regrets about that i have
lots of lessons about that
and the major lesson is do not
force women into this binary notion and
men
into this binary notion of balance
really help people understand that there
are going to be
parts and points in time where
you are maybe it's earlier in your
career
and you therefore are really putting
more effort and focus
on your work life you are still working
on your family your home etc but if you
are in partnership or in relationship
with someone
talk about that really really talk about
that
this is where you build community
together
and that is as i said it's not a regret
it's an observation and learning that
that i have that
uh i still hold out hope that my next
partnership not not not marriage or
husband
my next partnership i can bring some of
those bring some of those lessons to
beer but
you know unapologetically ambitious
beautiful beautiful how are we doing for
time
saba yeah we're doing great we have
exactly five minutes left
oh wow five minutes left in the meantime
kay
the participants have been suggesting a
number of wonderful books
oh i love that book oh you know i met
the dalai lama that was
that was truly the high point of them i
did meet the dalai lama it was the high
point of my life
yeah he does doesn't he he does
these are beautiful oh my gosh thank you
wow
we'll actually put together these uh the
list perfect
and of course scaling excellence how
could they not have that on the list
so you know we have five minutes
um you're a person who loves and admires
language i'm curious if there was a gift
you were going to leave our participants
with with just two words
to master for the next couple of months
as they're thinking about
what's which version of my life i want
to choose
what would those words be
and you know i always say context is
decisive
so this is you know the context that
we're in now
pandemic we are in uh
an era right now of extraordinary
divisiveness
right polarization let me call that
where
we are operating really in a binary
society you either
like me or you don't you're either with
me or you're not so there's
there's a lot of binary there's a binary
stance that's happening we're in the
midst of a pandemic
in some arenas kind of where i
where i quote-unquote hang out like down
in the tenderloin
um really significant pain
and suffering of the human kind so if i
could leave people
with anything at all i would leave them
with
yes humility because i think humility
allows you
to see the other person
so humility and sight and what i mean by
sight is and this happens all the time
we don't take the time to really see
people
and i learned that from working with or
on house population
and for for the benefit of the people
here i don't say homeless
i say unhoused and what i learned from
them
is so often they don't feel seen
because people step around them people
turn their head even if somebody's
offering them a cup of coffee
they are not looking at them so i'm
going to urge people
humility and sight humility
how you show up sight is just
just see people just see people
i love that i really love that angelia
trances
as a woman yes in capital letters
apologetically ambitious is a beautiful
trait
oh that's beautiful thank you but as all
of us leave please remember what
k foster has actually shared with you
today
through her not just her biography but
her character
and her kindness here's what i'm taking
away hopefully you are as well
the first thing i'm actually taking away
is
being a leader means being in the help
business
you have to help other people otherwise
there's no way you can be a leader is
what i heard
and the other thing is the two other
things that i take away is
one is i was so struck by casing it's
not
either or and the way i interpreted it
is don't suck them to a zero-sum bias
because once you have a zero-sum bias
you think it's a fixed pie
you're allocating and you then run into
all kinds of problems
by the way there is research that
suggests that the fixed pie
way of thinking is not just a
psychological bias
but actually a western cultural trait
yes other countries other cultures you
don't necessarily
have something to sort of think about
and the third thing i'm so
struck about sight see people
and the way i'm interpreting that is
it's not only seeing
other people but the way you see
yourself yes
and i think what i'm taking away from k
is
see others as persons don't deperson
them
as categories yes homeless
this or that whatever yes so don't put
them into categories
person them and if you person them
you will person yourself too because
when you de-person them
you are unpersoning yourself and as
always
in an afternoon with or in an evening
with k i go back with so many new
understandings and this is why we enjoy
doing this
i just want all of you to join me in
giving an electronic
you know applause as it were for the
amazing
k foster so